in the last video we did a quick review
of the exponential and what it means and
then we looked and figured out what the
magnitude of an exponential is the
magnitude is equal to 1 now we're going
to look closely at this this complex
exponential as it represents a cosine a
part of a cosine
now we're going to keep combining some
of our ideas from the last couple of
videos and you remember if we one of the
things we did was we used Oilers formula
and turn it inside out and developed an
expression for cosine so if I say cosine
of theta I can say that equals 1/2 times
e to the plus J theta plus e to the
minus J theta this is cosine of theta
expressed as two separate Exponential's
and now we're going to take a really
special step I'm going to put in an
argument right here of time I'm going to
say cosine of Omega T T is time and this
shape here this symbol here is the
lowercase Omega from the Greek alphabet
and that's the frequency so time is in
units of seconds and Omega is a
frequency so it's in in the units of 1
over seconds
that's the units of frequency or per
seconds and when these multiply together
we get dimensionless number right here
and we can take the cosine of a
dimensionless number so what is this
equal to this equals 1/2 times e to the
plus J Omega T plus e to the minus J
Omega T when we make T the argument of
the cosine here T is this stuff that
keeps going up and up and up
the number T gets just gets bigger all
the time and so we ended up with a
cosine wave form and I'll just make a
bad cosine looking thing here that's
what a cosine looks like and it keeps
going and going and going so we have an
idea of what a cosine wave looks like
the frequency determines how fast this
goes up and down or how often it goes up
and down but now what I want to do is I
want to look at a very special thing I
want to look at what is this thing right
here what is this thing e to the plus J
Omega T
and what we see is this cosine here is
made of two of these things so whatever
these things are I can make a cosine out
of them so now we're going to look
really carefully at e to the J Omega T
what we just reviewed was that this is a
complex number let's let's draw that
complex number
you
so we're going to put a number out here
we know it falls on the unit circle we
know it's angle is whatever is
multiplying the J up in this exponent
whatever it's up in the exponent is the
angle of this thing so this angle right
here is Omega T and we know the
magnitude of this is as we decided
before the magnitude is 1 that's why it
falls on the on the unit circle okay so
now look at this here's this number T
that's determining the angle and that
means what that means that the angle is
increasing with time if time is equal to
zero the point is right here at time
equals zero because angle is zero as
time proceeds the angle keet starts
growing and growing and it basically
keeps growing and it keeps going
comes back to here after Omega T equals
to PI and then what happens it goes
keeps going around it again and this
basically goes along for as long as time
goes along so here's this number here's
this complex number moving along the
unit circle in time over and over and
over again so this is a number that is
rotating the number is rotating
so I can write here e to the J Omega T
and I know that that because times up
here I know it's rotating in time all
right now I'm going to put a different
number on there let's put it over here
say well let's actually start this
number at zero and I'm going to call
this number e to the minus J Omega T
what does that number look like that's
this guy here that's this one here will
make him orange so at time equals zero
it's e to the zero or one just as we
would expect now as time gets bigger the
angle the thing multiplying J is minus
Omega T and so the angle is becoming
more and more negative so after a little
bit of time it's here and after a little
bit more time it's here and what we
notice is it keeps it rotates this way
this is what happens when you have e to
the minus J Omega T you rotate in this
direction and it keeps going and going
and going so these two numbers are
pretty similar in behavior except one
rotates counterclockwise and the other
rotates clockwise in our coordinate
system which is the complex plane so in
summary if you see either of these
shapes e to the minus plus J Omega T or
e to the minus J Omega T what pops into
your head is a number that spins so for
me the simple idea is I have a number
here and I have a number here they both
spin in the complex space and to
represent those in in mathematical
notation I need this kind of notation
here which is a little bit awkward but
as I get used to it
e to the J Omega T it's a spinning
number e to the minus J Omega T is a
spinning number this is an amazingly
powerful idea and will be able to
describe every signal that happens using
these kind of terms